[Music]
the task of philosophy is synthesis
taking all the things we know to be true
in different ways of course scientific
truth some experiments but also the
reality of our own Consciousness the
reality perhaps of value
and the kind of mathematical truths that
we know about through mathematical
intuition taking all these things we
know and
bringing them together synthesizing them
into a world view that's the
the ancient Noble task of philosophy
that I think we've lost sight of and we
need to come back to and hopefully out
of that active synthesis
will emerge
a picture of reality that in which we
can find a place in which we can live
our meaning out in a way that's
rationally acceptable scientifically
plausible but also good for our mental
and spiritual health